queremos saber cuánto es un cuarto más
tres quintos menos tres decimos los
animo a que pasen el vídeo y vean si
pueden resolver esto por ustedes mismos
muy bien supongo que lo han intentado
así que vamos a hacer esto juntos lo
primero que hacemos es ver estas
fracciones que estamos sumando y
restando y nos damos cuenta de que
tienen diferentes denominador es así que
para sumarlas y restar las de una manera
razonable las tenemos que reescribir
para que tengan el mismo denominador lo
que realmente queremos hacer es
encontrar un común múltiplo de 4 5 y 10
y podemos usar cualquier múltiplo común
pero para simplificar las cosas lo mejor
es que usemos el mínimo común múltiplo y
una manera de encontrar el mínimo común
múltiplo es tomar el mayor de los
números y encontrar sus múltiplos e ir
incrementando los múltiplos hasta
encontrar uno que sea divisible entre
los otros dos así que por ejemplo voy a
tratar con el 10 10 es divisible entre 5
pero no es divisible entre 4 así que
vamos con el 20
20 es divisible entre 5 y entre 4 así
que el mínimo común múltiplo de 4 5 y 10
es 20 entonces dejen de reescribir estas
fracciones como algo sobre 20 y vamos a
empezar con un cuarto
un cuarto es igual a que sobre 20 para
pasar del 4 al 20 tenemos que
multiplicar por 5 y tenemos que hacer lo
mismo con el numerador tenemos que
multiplicar por 5 1 por 5 es igual a 5 1
sobre 4 es lo mismo que 5 sobre 20 4 es
igual a 4 por 1 y 20 es igual a 4 por 5
luego tenemos que pensar qué pasa con
tres quintos lo quiere escribir como
algo sobre 20 si en el denominador voy
del 5 al 20 tengo que multiplicar el
denominador por 4 así que tengo que
multiplicar el numerador por 4 también
entonces 3 por 4 es igual a 12 y luego
vamos a restar 3 decimos entonces
tenemos que reescribir esto como algo
sobre 20 cuando vamos de 10 a 20
multiplicamos el denominador por 2 así
que si queremos tener la misma fracción
también tenemos que multiplicar el
numerador por 2 entonces 3 por 2 es
igual a 6
así que ahora cuál es el resultado de
todo esto bueno tengo 520 abós más 12 20
a vos menos 6 20 a vos a que es igual
cuál es el resultado hay muchas maneras
en que podemos pensar en esto y podemos
decir que esto va a ser igual
520 a vos más 12 20 a vos menos 620 a
vos esta es otra forma de verlo por eso
lo escribe así 5 más 12 6 y todo esto
sobre 20 esto es cuántos 20 años van a
resultar así que cuál es el resultado
tenemos que volver a contar los 20 a vos
y entonces 5 12 es 17 menos 6 es igual a
el resultado es 11 20 a vos si tengo 5
20 a vos y le sumó 12 20 a vos y luego
le restó 6 20 a vos
voy a tener como resultado 11 20 a vos
vamos a hacer otro ejemplo de esto para
practicar un poco más
aquí tenemos cuatro novenos menos un
sexto más un tercio y como en el ejemplo
anterior los anima que pausa en el vídeo
para que traten de resolver lo bueno lo
que quiero hacer es reescribir todas
estas fracciones con un denominador
común encontrar un denominador común un
mínimo común múltiplo para 9
y 3 y como lo hice antes voy a empezar
con el 9
vamos a ver 9 9 no es divisible entre 6
si es divisible entre 3 pero no entre 6
y lo que necesito es encontrar un común
múltiplo entre 96 y 3 lo más pequeño
posible así que voy a tratar con el
siguiente múltiplo de 9 que es 18 y 18
es divisible entre 9 por supuesto entre
6 y entre 3 así que el mínimo común
múltiplo que estamos buscando es 18
vamos a escribir todo en términos de 18
a bosch entonces 4 novenos es que sobre
18 bueno 9 por 2 es igual a 18 y si hago
eso en el denominador también tengo que
multiplicar el numerador por 2 entonces
esto es igual a 8 sobre 18 y ahora
cuánto es un sexto en 18 bosh bueno para
ir de 6 a 18 en el denominador tengo que
multiplicar por 3 así que también voy a
multiplicar el numerador por 3
1 por 3 es igual a 3 y ahora el último
cuánto es un tercio en 18 bosh bueno 3
por 6 es igual a 18 entonces 1 por 6 es
igual a 6 o lo podemos ver de otra forma
cuanto es un tercio de 18 y es 6 cuanto
es un sexto de 18 y es igual a 3 y
cuánto es 4 novenos de 18 y esto es un
poco más difícil para el cerebro pero es
igual a 8 18 a bosch y ya reescribir
todas estas fracciones con el color
correspondiente todo esto que tenemos
aquí es lo mismo 8 18 a bosch menos 3 18
a vos más 6 18 bosh así que cuál es el
resultado de esto y va a ser igual a un
número de 18 28 18 a vos menos 318 a vos
es igual a 5 18 a vos más 618 a vos es
igual a 11 18 a vos y hemos terminado